so i wish we'd known this about ilhan
omar which voters had known that but
government covered it up they've also
been hiding the truth about ufos that's
true we did a whole documentary on it
for our tucker carlson original series
we took a look at what our leaders have
been hiding
it's just out here's part of it
when the government isn't lying about
what they're seeing they're hiding what
they know
you can see they would black out nearly
everything on all of the pages they
didn't want to talk about it
sunshine laws give americans the right
to appeal the blacked out portions
within government documents when i asked
the nsa to do that they mysteriously
lost each and every one of the hundreds
of pages that they had collected the
reality of the nsa losing all of that on
ufos is nil that's the length that they
will go to to try and cover this up the
government knows more than it's letting
on but i'm not convinced even the
government have all the answers here
even inside the u.s government secrecy
is the rule
after pilot chad underwood spotted the
famous flying tic tac he learned that a
navy missile cruiser nearby had been
tracking it for weeks we still have
never seen that video
that's up tomorrow morning on fox nation
you can stream it then
pretty amazing documentary actually hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else